what's the point of travel it's to help
make us
into better people it's a sort of
therapy
without anything mystical being meant by
this all of us
are in one way or another on what could
be termed an
inner journey that is we're trying to
develop in particular ways
in a nutshell the point of travel is to
go to places
that can help us in our inner evolution
the
outer journey should assist us with the
inner one
every location in the world contains
qualities that can support
some kind of beneficial change inside a
person
take these 200 million year old stones
in america's utah desert
it's a place but looked at
psychologically it's also
an inner destination a place with
perspective
free of preoccupation with the petty in
the small-minded
somewhere imbued with calm and
resilience
religions used to take travel much more
seriously than we do now
for them it was a therapeutic activity
in the middle ages
when there was something wrong with you
you were meant to head out for a
pilgrimage
to commune with relics of a saint or a
member of the holy family
if you had toothache you'd go to rome to
the basilica of san lorenzo
and touch the arm bones of saint
apollonia the patron saint of teeth
if you were unhappily married you might
go to umbria to touch the shrine of
saint rita of caskia
patron saint of marital problems or if
you were worried about lightning
you were sent a bad munsterfeld in
germany to touch the skull of saint
donatus
believed to offer help against fires and
explosions
we no longer believe in the divine power
of journeys
but certain parts of the world still
have a power to change and mend the
wounded parts of us
in an ideal world travel agencies will
be manned
by a new kind of psychotherapist they
take care not just of the flights and
the hotels
they'd start by finding out what was
wrong with us and how we might want to
change
the anxious might be sent to see the
majestic immemorial waves
crashing into the cliffs on the west
coast of ireland
people a bit too concerned with being
admired and famous
might be sent to contemplate the ruins
of detroit
someone out of touch with their body
might be recommended a trip to puerto
seguro in bahia and brazil
nowadays too often we head off without
fully knowing what's wrong with us
or precisely understanding how our
chosen destination is meant to help us
we should become more conscious
travellers on a well articulated search
for qualities that places possess
like calm or perspective sensuality or
rigor
we should follow old-fashioned pilgrims
in striving to evolve our characters
according to the suggestions offered up
by the places we've been to
we need to re-learn how to be ambitious
about travel
seeing it as a way of helping us to grow
into better versions
of ourselves
you